[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public votre
rendez-vous de débat et de reportage sur
Public Sénat tous les jours 18 heures 22
heures du lundi au jeudi 90 minutes pour
donner du sens à l'actualité 90 minutes
et deux grands thèmes la guerre en
Ukraine d'abord et cette étape cruciale
l'Allemagne a finalement accepté de
livrer des chars lourds léopard derrière
elle d'autres pays européens les
États-Unis vont accentuer leur aide
militaire comment va réagir la Russie
a-t-il un risque d'escalade la France
va-t-elle participer avec ces chars
Leclerc réponses de nos experts dans une
minute et puis pour notre second débat
des bas de société volontairement décalé
de l'actualité du jour je vous propose
un gros plan sur un ratage celui du
dispositif m'a prisme rénove et plus
globalement de notre politique de
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments on
va parler de fiasco mais on n'est pas
loin de ça puisqu'on devrait rénover
allez 600
000 passoires thermiques par an
l'année dernière on en a rénové 2500 il
y a des millions de passoires thermiques
à rénover des milliards d'euros à
dépenser mais ça n'avance pas assez vite
on va tenter de comprendre pourquoi tout
à l'heure mais d'abord donc cette
décision de la chancelier allemand
débloque c'est Charles léopard c'est la
fin d'une crise politique le début d'une
nouvelle ère sur le front ukrainien
Jérôme Rabier c'était une demande de
longue date des Ukrainiens et un sujet
de tension entre Ali et occidentaux
l'Allemagne va finalement envoyer des
chars léopardeux aux forces ukrainiennes
Miss sous pression sur ce sujet le
chancelier allemand Olaf scholls la
confirmé aujourd'hui
nous allons également fournir à
l'Ukraine des chars de combat léopard 2
c'est le résultat d'une consultation
intensive une fois de plus avec nos
alliés et nos partenaires internationaux
il s'agit pour l'instant de 14 chars
mais l'Allemagne a surtout autorisé les
autres pays européens qui ont disposent
à livrer ses chars de fabrication
allemande ce que réclamait notamment la
Pologne depuis plusieurs semaines la
Finlande la Norvège les Pays-Bas et
aujourd'hui l'Espagne ont aussi confirmé
leur volonté d'en fournir à l'Ukraine à
court terme ce sont 80 chars léopards
qui pourraient venir appuyer les forces
ukrainiennes si l'Allemagne a fini par
donner son feu vert c'est sous la
pression internationale le président
américain Joe Biden doit confirmer que
les États-Unis fourniront de leur côté
une trentaine de chars lourds Abrahams
une façon diplomatique de dire que les
modèles allemands ne seront pas les
seuls envoyés sur le terrain côté
français si l'on voit du Charles clair
est officiellement à l'étude la première
ministre a préféré insister au Sénat sur
les autres livraisons effectuées par la
France
s'agissant des chars Leclerc nous
poursuivons l'analyse avec le ministre
des Armées la question de l'aide à
l'Ukraine ne se limite pas à tel ou tel
équipement chaque pays dispose de
domaines d'excellence comme la défense
aérienne et l'artillerie pour la France
il est important de bien nous coordonner
les canons d'artillerie français César
sont notamment plébiscités par les
Ukrainiens alors que l'on voit de
Charles Leclerc en petite quantité
pourrait poser des problèmes de
logistique et d'entretien le modèle
allemand bénéficie lui d'un grand stock
en Europe ce qui facilitera l'envoi de
munitions comme deux pièces de rechange
en cas de besoin
j'accueille tout de suite les invités du
1er débat de ce sens public Gérard
longhey bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes sénateur et l'ère de la Meuse
ancien ministre de la Défense et
président du groupe d'amitié France
Russie au Sénat Tenzer bonsoir bonsoir
bienvenue à vous aussi enseignants
Sciences Po Paris et directeur du
journal en ligne deskrie Martin Genier
bonsoir bienvenue spécialisé question
européenne et enseignants à Sciences Po
Mathieu croissanto bonsoir Mathieu
éditorialiste politique confirmation de
l'information qui était évoquée par
Jérôme Rabier dans dans ce sujet un haut
responsable américain vient d'annoncer
que la Russie allait livrer 31 chars
Abraham j'ai dit la Russie lapsus
intéressant les États-Unis vont livrer
31 chars Abrams à l'Ukraine Gérard
Longuet est-ce que c'est je disais en
titre une une nouvelle ère sur le front
ukrainien est-ce que vous dites ça vous
aussi des chars lourds parce que là on
peut imaginer que plusieurs pays vont
suivre oui il y a une d'abord il y a une
signification politique ça veut dire que
ceux qui soutiennent la l'Ukraine sont
solidaires reste solidaire et envisage
ce qui est un signal fort pour la Russie
envisage de jouer plus gros s'il le faut
alors donc il y a un aspect dissuasion
ensuite il y a un aspect tactique quel
usage
et quel logistique là c'est beaucoup
beaucoup plus difficile
les Césars les autres au musées sont
assez autonomes les chats appartiennent
à un système de combat qui suppose une
stratégie d'ensemble qui suppose une
logistique d'ensemble qui suppose une
coordination avec d'autres forces plus
difficiles évidemment rentrera dans le
détail Nicolas Tenzer et est-ce que ça
peut faire basculer l'issue de cette
guerre ce à quoi on est en train
d'assister en ce moment alors pas encore
c'est à dire que concrètement il faut
saluer ces livraisons qui sont une étape
évidemment tout à fait importante
maintenant il faut savoir effectivement
infinés combien de chars seront livrés
combien de chars léopard là on annonce
80 ce n'est certainement pas assez il en
faudrait au moins 200 à 300 les chats
Abraham ça il devrait y en avoir donc 31
livrer par les États-Unis là aussi c'est
un peu peu donc il faudrait quand même
qui est une force massive si l'on entend
donner les moyens aux forces
ukrainiennes de reconquérir l'ensemble
du territoire perdu et de faire
respecter l'intégrité territoriale
entière totale de l'Ukraine maintenant
effectivement je rebondis sur ce que
disait Gérard Longuet je pense que les
chars c'est une partie évidemment de la
des composantes armées en fait il y a
trois composantes si on veut reconquérir
véritablement le pays si on est sérieux
là-dessus c'est d'une part effectivement
les chats deuxièmement pour frapper dans
la profondeur des missiles de longues
portées et ça fait très longtemps que
l'Ukraine demande aux États-Unis de
fournir des Attachés américains avec une
portée de 300 km alors que les imams
c'est un peu près 80 km et puisqu'il
faudrait aussi parce que là aussi ça
permet de frapper dans
de donner les moyens de faire cela
encore une fois sur des sites militaires
d'ailleurs les Ukrainiens à la
différence des Russes de vis que des
cibles militaires Patrick Martin Genet
si on revient sur la question de ces de
ces chars lourds
donc on a l'Allemagne qui a fait cette
annonce les États-Unis qui viennent
d'annoncer les Charentes il y a d'autres
pays d'Europe qui qui possèdent des
chars léopard 2 qui attendaient le
pourquoi d'ailleurs attendait-il
l'autorisation de l'Allemagne ou le ou
la décision allemande avant de de se
lancer à leur tour parce que la décision
était délicate il y a un problème
politique naturellement mais il y a un
problème juridique lorsque vous signez
un contrat qu'un ministre va signer un
contrat d'armement et bien c'est destiné
à un pays ce n'est pas destiné à une
exportation officielle ou officieuse
d'un autre pays donc c'est vrai que ma
problème juridique important mais avant
tout la décision était politique et on
voit bien que la chose c'est très
hésitant là-dessus le mini le Premier
ministre polonais était extrêmement en
colère vis-à-vis de l'Allemagne le le
conseiller présidentiel
ukrainien également en disant que
pendant que on on continue à tuer en
Ukraine donc évidemment il y avait une
hésitation juridique et politique il y a
d'autres pays qui vont suivre l'Espagne
à des centaines de charlés par deux
parce que sauf qu'ils sont pas forcément
en très bon état
il y en a 2500 si bien compris tout en
Europe donc vous disiez tout à l'heure
qu'il en fallait entre 200 et 300 oui
c'est à peu près le chiffre qu'il faut
200 300 si on veut leur donner
effectivement un appui logistique et
militaire très important sur le terrain
et vous savez on a entendu rail métal
aussi de fabricant allemand de dire il y
a quelques gens que finalement on ne
pouvait pas les livrer avant 2024 et que
le stock était là présent il fallait
tout démonter et remonter et voilà 24
heures ou 48 heures à une métal d'un
seul coup dit bah si moi je peux en
livrer environ une quarantaine d'ici le
mois de mars 2023 donc ce qui veut dire
quand même avant tout une décision
politique et effectivement dans la
mesure où le véto allemand a été levé
sous la pression des États-Unis je pense
effectivement que d'autres pays vont
pouvoir exporter ou autoriser d'autres
pays à livrer ce genre de char à
l'Ukraine alors cette question de la
temporalité du calendrier de livraison
évidemment et d'utilisation de séchage
elle est cruciale écouter scandie le
secrétaire américain à la Défense
nous avons ici une fenêtre d'opportunité
entre maintenant et le printemps dès
qu'il commence leur opération leur
contre-offensive ce n'est pas une longue
période et nous devons réunir les
capacités nécessaires pour y arriver
alors Gérard Longuet cette fenêtre
d'opportunité est-ce que les chats qui
vont être livrés peuvent entrer dans
cette fenêtre d'opportunité en quelque
sorte ça veut dire être opérationnel
avant le printemps puisque manifestement
c'est ce que c'est ce qui est recherché
sachant que vous avez commencé à
l'évoquer c'est pas si simple il y a un
temps de formation d'apprentissage non
en tous les cas pour le Leclerc je
connais moins la situation de léopard
mais pour les Leclerc l'équipage de
trois hommes il faut 4 mois pour même si
les gens sont combatifs et mobilisés
pour les amener au niveau ensuite un
char ça fait partie d'un ensemble donc
il y a des réseaux de communication il y
a un réseau de fluides de soutien de
carburant et puis de pièces détachées
parce que
immobilisé pour une pièce à 50 balles un
char qui vaut des millions d'euros et
qui a une utilité tactique considérable
c'est simplement pas possible donc il
faut avoir sur place des gens capables
d'intervenir rapidement
je pense que le la première utilité de
ces annonces est une utilité dans la
dans la dissuasion réciproque en fait
une les Russes se posent la question de
savoir jusqu'où ira la solidarité de
ceux qui soutiennent l'Ukraine là il
s'aperçoivent que la la solidarité est
plus solide qu'il ne le pensait c'est la
première utilité des chats leur utilité
est tactique à part peut-être les
Léopards polonais
avec des équipages sur lesquels nous
jetterons un voile pudique c'est en
effet dans le créneau de temps du
printemps d'accord et on reviendra sur
le la question des chars Leclerc tout à
l'heure Patrick Martin je n'y a
effectivement donc il y a le risque
d'avoir quoi des des forces disparates
finalement si d'un côté imaginons là
dans les dans les semaines qui viennent
il y a d'un côté des chars américains
Abrahams de l'autre des chats d'origine
allemande de léopard II c'est pas
forcément les mêmes systèmes d'armes et
ce qui sont compatible les uns avec les
autres comment on les fait travailler
ensemble et les communications et les
communications
elle a pas vu que pour les chats il
avait d'autres également ça pose des
problèmes de coordination mais il
semblerait que c'est vrai il y avait une
hésitation une hostilité américaine
parce qu'on considérait que les chars
abravent c'était pas forcément les plus
adaptés qu'ils étaient difficiles qui
consommaient beaucoup de carburant il y
a aussi l'alimentation carburant qu'il
faut à laquelle il faut penser il
semblerait que les chats les plus
opérationnels les plus efficaces se sont
effectivement les Léopards 2 allemands
ce qui est bien pour ça qu'ils sont en
Europe il y en a 2500 donc si on doit
faire un effort effectivement sûr ces
chats ce sont sur les chars allemands ce
sont pas non plus sur les chars
britanniques une quinzaine vont être
envoyés là-bas en Ukraine donc je crois
que dans un premier temps il y a un
message politique très important comme
vous disiez il y a une vraie solidarité
européenne le temps enfin accepte avec
l'Allemagne d'envoyer des charlés par
deux qu'il y ait des problèmes
techniques de formation oui c'est
important et c'est d'ailleurs peut-être
à l'origine de la réticence ou de
l’écitation du gouvernement français à
ce mais est-ce que ça veut dire Nicolas
Tenzer que ce que vous disiez jetons à
voile pudique sur ceux qui vont manier
ses chats en quelque sorte ça veut dire
qu'il va y avoir des des soldats
allemands polonais espagnol ou des
techniciens qui vont qui vont être sur
le terrain sur de guerre en Ukraine ils
ont les choses voilà je pense que c'est
totalement nécessaire c'est d'ailleurs
ce pourquoi je plaidais dès le 24
février à vrai dire je pense
qu'effectivement à partir du moment où
on décide d'aider l'Ukraine à
reconquérir tout son territoire il faut
y mettre les moyens et qu'avoir
effectivement des techniciens un certain
nombre d'ingénieurs de mécaniciens etc
sur place c'est totalement indispensable
mais c'est pas neutre symboliquement et
pas seulement une fois on est on est
toujours dans l'article dans le cadre de
l'article 51 la Charte des Nations
uniques j'évoquais c'est-à-dire qu'on a
un état agressé par un autre État
d'accord mais est-ce qu'on peut on peut
considérer qu'on est toujours pas
belligérant
alors encore une fois la notion de
combat je suis d'accord avec
l'expression de genre à Longuet le voile
pudique effectivement je me paraît
relativement sage mais
c'est une notion russe c'est une notion
effectivement qui juridiquement hors
déclaration de guerre mais aujourd'hui
on déclare plus la guerre officiellement
n'a strictement aucun sens c'est-à-dire
que la cobelligérance c'est l'autre en
l'occurrence la Russie qui peut nous
accuser mais il n'y a pas de limite qui
permet d'indiquer un seuil sur le plan
du droit ça il faut être très clair
là-dessus c'est un dernier informations
en cette fin d'après-midi la Norvège va
envoyer des chars léopard 2 à l'Ukraine
voilà on est dans on est clairement dans
une séquence qui a été préparée on sait
que Joe Biden a appelé plusieurs de ses
homologues qui est absolument
passionnante pour la construction
européenne parce qu'on s'aperçoit avec
des pays qu'on jugeait tranquilles
serein la Finlande qui avait des raisons
de se méfier mais qui était prudentes
depuis toujours
la Suède dont la réputation n'est pas
belliqueuse la Norvège qu'il est encore
moins s'engage que la Pologne et pays
balles directement concernés s'engage on
pouvait le comprendre mais que des pays
du nord de l'Europe du Nord s'en c'est
plus spectaculaire et donc c'est ça nous
interpelle nous Français je crois que la
situation du président Macron n'est pas
très facile parce qu'il va falloir qu'il
se prononce pour l'instant ministre le
corps nu nous dit Madame borne étudie ma
faille il y a quand même un moment il
faut répondre et alors la Constitution
française je vous le rappelle permet au
président de la République
alors il s'agit pas d'engager des forces
françaises il s'agit de vendre enfin de
vendre de prêter du matériel un peu un
peu subtil quand même comme différence
pour les Russes je pense très
honnêtement que ce matériel là
apparaîtra
pour belligérance je suis d'accord ça ne
veut rien dire mais comme une
implication très forte d'autant plus que
la question est quand même simple à quoi
vont servir les chats s'il s'agit de
percer des lignes pour arriver très vite
sur la frontière c'est pas tout à fait
la même chose que de délivrer une ville
encerclé sur le front diplomatique
Mathieu on va s'intéresser à cette
entretien entre Emmanuel Macron et
volody mirzelanski hier soir oui c'est
pas un tweet du président ukrainien
qu'on a appris la nouvelle un suivi d'un
communiqué de l'Elysée dans la foulée
alors c'est bien sûr pas là de première
fois que les que les deux hommes
échangent mais on sait se souvient qu'on
vient de relations a pu paraître au
début un peu compliqué volo du meilleur
Zelinski elle entend rapprocher à son
homologue français
de maintenir le dialogue avec Vladimir
Poutine plutôt que d'épouser plus
fermement j'allais dire plus
militairement la cause des Ukrainiens
agressée mais de l'eau a coulé sous les
ponts depuis le fil n'est pas
complètement rompu avec Moscou depuis
Paris mais on peut pas dire que il y a
vraiment beaucoup d'échanges et puis
Emmanuel Macron ne serait plus en
médiateur dans ce conflit ce qui était
un peu la position initiale qu'il
envisageait et puis la France est
aujourd'hui le troisième contributeur
mondial pour l'effort de guerre en
Ukraine à la fois par le pays européen
et par son engagement national selon le
classement effectué par l'Institut de
Kehl et Kiev a notamment été très
sensible de voir Paris prendre la tête
de la communauté internationale vous
souvenez au mois de décembre pour
organiser la première conférence des
donateurs voilà une façon de montrer
pour Emmanuel Macron que la France était
là aujourd'hui et quelle serait là aussi
demain donc sans surprise le ton est
désormais beaucoup plus amical et volo
dumien zalaski n'a pas manqué de
remercier comme ça publiquement Emmanuel
Macron pour le soutien français alors
officiellement de quoi ont-ils parlé
alors il a été évidemment question de la
situation humanitaire j'ai envie de dire
mais surtout militaire du pays
selon les comptes rendus de Kiev comme
comme ceux de l'Elysée le président
zenas qui a remercié la France pour les
livraisons de systèmes de défense
anti-aériens et puis pour l'envoi de de
char de combat dit léger les fameuses
amix mais pas de communication
officielle en tout cas des deux parties
sur la fameuse question des chars
Leclerc sans doute parce que Isabelle
borne il réfléchit encore plus sacmment
et puis il y a eu des droits bien sûr
des remerciements aussi parce que c'est
vrai que c'est pas une décision à
prendre à la légère on y reviendra et
puis il y a des remerciements aussi pour
le soutien logistique c'est-à-dire je
parle des générateurs d'électricité
voilà des choses comme ça et puis ils
ont également discuté diplomatie et
perspective de paix Paris a rappelé à
Kiev qu'il soutenait la proposition
ukrainienne le fameux plan de paix en 10
points qui est suffisamment
j'allais dire chantourner ou ambigu pour
qu'on comprenne que faudrait revenir aux
frontières de de 2014 et plus étonnant
de prime abord ils ont même parlé de
sport oui alors avec cette demande
surprise du président zenaski à propos
des prochains jeux olympiques Paris
2024f souhaite de voir les athlètes de
la Fédération de Russie tout simplement
banni des JO ce qui est pas forcément
une décision qui appartient à Paris mais
plutôt au Comité international olympique
on le sait mais en tout cas c'est une
demande pour l'instant sans réponse
officielle de la part de Paris
puisqu'elle ne figure même pas dans le
communiqué qu'on a fait merci Mathieu
Patrick Martin Genier est-ce que si on
reste sur la finalement ce fil
diplomatique de du président Macron
depuis quasiment un an depuis le début
de ce conflit est-ce que son évolution
elle est pas un peu contrainte et forcée
comment vous l'analysez écoutez c'est
vrai que la France a toujours voulu dans
une perspective gaulliste jouer la
troisième voie en disant on peut
s'inscrire dans une troisième voie entre
les États-Unis et la Russie c'était un
peu l'héritage du général de Gaulle qui
avait toujours voulu entretenir de
bonnes relations avec l'est mais depuis
cette guerre c'est vrai que dans un
premier temps Emmanuel Macron a voulu
s'inscrire dans cet héritage c'était
très mal vécu en Ukraine très mal vécue
rappelez-vous les propos du président de
la République comme quoi ne fallait pas
humilier la Russie dans un premier temps
il l'avait dit je réitère ses propos et
je les assume complètement il a été
beaucoup critiqué par la communauté
internationale et notamment par
volodymerzeninski et donc on a vu
effectivement qu'il a évoluer à ce sujet
il a voulu s'inscrire vous l'avez dit en
médiateur il a appelé les dizaines de
fois le chef donc Vladimir Poutine il a
appelé également le chef de l'État
ukrainien etc et il a bien vu
effectivement que ça ne marchait pas je
crois que quelque part il a été déçu il
pensait pouvoir s'inscrire en médiateur
dans la tradition Gauliste de la France
mais il a vu que Vladimir Poutine
n'était pas un homme à qui on pouvait
avoir confiance et donc il a été obligé
d'évoluer et très déçu effectivement il
a été sur ce point et donc aujourd'hui
et bien il s'inscrit effectivement dans
une posture bien plus en opposition avec
Vladimir Poutine même si j'ai cru
comprendre que pour la livraison des
chats Leclerc il avait dit que cela
devait ne devait pas s'inscrire encore
une fois dans une perspective
escalatatoire ce qui veut dire que
voilà ce qui veut dire aujourd'hui qu'il
essaye de continuer à entretenir un fil
diplomatique avec Vladimir Poutine
s'agissant de la France on ne saurait le
lui reprocher alors ce mot escalatoires
on y reviendra un peu plus tard si vous
le voulez bien mais Gérard Longuet je
reste sur la diplomatie d'Emmanuel
Macron finalement c'est le rôle de la
diplomatie maintenant un lien même avec
les ennemis oui donc il a eu raison de
le faire il a rien fait récemment non
mais en tout cas pendant les premiers
mois du conflit oui mais je pense
franchement que le le conflit évolue
nous avons constaté dans un premier
temps que l'effet de surprise russe
n'avait pas fonctionné dans un deuxième
temps que la Russie n'était même pas
capable de tenir ses positions initiales
puis la Russie s'est ressaisie il y a eu
cette conscription importante qui n'est
pas enfin qui c'est un piste 140
millions d'habitants 300 000 conscristes
importants c'est pas décisif mais c'est
quand même très important et donc la
relation avec petit ne change nécessaire
[Musique]
parler aujourd'hui beaucoup plus
difficile on s'aperçoit qu'on a
quelqu'un qui ne reculera de vente aucun
moyen pour
casser d'abord la solidarité autour de
l'Ukraine et surtout
anéantir ce pays enfin il y a une vraie
véritable volonté de destruction et bon
il peut l'appeler pour lui dire tu vois
bien tu montes la barre et bien nous on
suit un petit peu comme carte vous
mettez une mise sur le tapis et les
alliés de l'Ukraine mettent une mise
plus forte simplement quand on met une
mise plus forte il faut savoir qu'on
peut la perdre également et pour le
président Macron moi je pense que sa
situation n'est pas facile et que nous
aurions intérêt nous Français en parler
un petit peu profondément entre nous
parlementaire par exemple Nicolas
tenzerbi intervenir sur ce thème oui
effectivement je pense que aujourd'hui
on s'aperçoit enfin on aurait dû le
savoir beaucoup plus que Vladimir
Poutine est effectivement dans une
logique jusqu'au-boutiste c'est à dire
qu'il est prêt à sacrifier d'ailleurs
lui-même toutes ses forces s'il devait
faire tuer un million de ces hommes pour
essayer de détruire l'Ukraine il le
ferait parce que la vie humaine pour lui
n'a strictement aucun prix donc il y a
pas d'autres options que de montrer les
muscles militairement aujourd'hui qui
est en train de se dire il n'y a pas
d'autres option en plus je dirais on
sait très bien que l'Ukraine n'est pas
le seul pays d'ailleurs menacé de leur
attaqué par la Russie quand même 20% du
territoire Géorgie est encore
aujourd'hui sous emprise russe qu'il
soutient le dictateur criminel ou
cachenko mais la Russe que les frappes
continuent on en parle beaucoup moins
elles sont moins meurtrières qui a 2 ou
3 ans en Syrie également qu'il soutient
la jeune birmane que vous avez toujours
des interférences dans les démocraties
occidentales et dans d'autres pays je
pense au pays des Balkans il y a
effectivement l'Afrique effectivement où
il menace directement d'ailleurs les
positions françaises et les positions
et puis il y a une immensité
maximum jamais l'oublier l'immensité des
crimes commis c'est à dire qu'à un
moment quand vous avez une centaine au
moins de milliers de personnes tuées
délibérément des civils tous les jours
assassinés vous avez eu les chambres de
torture vous avez tout ce qu'on a pu
voir je dirais depuis le début
effectivement il n'y a pas d'autres
solutions je dirais devant un criminel
de cette nature que de dire il doit être
jugé il faut le vaincre pour la sécurité
de l'Ukraine et pour la nôtre j'entends
ça un dernier mot là-dessus et après on
parle des chars Leclerc
évidemment Vladimir Poutine on l'a
entendu parler de paix mais que signifie
la paix pour lui il s'agit de
reconnaissance unilatérale des
addictions des républiques qu'il a
envahi annexé dans le Dombas assez
ailleurs à Kerson zapporica et c'est la
reconnaissance de facto et l'endroit par
la communauté internationale de ces
annexes absolument incompatible avec le
plan de paix qui a été proposé par
zenaski qui exige l'arrêt des hostilités
le cesser de feu
d'une part comme on l'a toujours fait
depuis le début que ça ne soit pas
escalatoire
et nous avons toujours eu cette ligne la
deuxième c'est que ça puisse apporter un
soutien réel et efficace à nos amis
ukrainiens
quel est l'état réel des stocks je
propose à mathiasaray de nous rejoindre
sur ce plateau bonsoir Mathias réponse à
cette question les tariels des stocks et
bien ce qu'il faut commencer par dire
c'est qu'il n'y a pas de chiffre
officiel précis on dispose que
d'estimation et aujourd'hui disons les
choses les stocks sont bas l'armée
française compte environ 400 Charles
clair mais et c'est bien le problème
tous ne sont pas mobilisables ou en
ligne selon les termes techniques plus
de la moitié des effectifs sont hors
d'usage ou alors servent de parc de
stock de pièces détachées par
cannibalisation pour ceux qui restent et
ce n'est pas fini sur lesquels que 200
restants environ 50 à 80 se trouve chez
l'industriel pour modernisation ce qui
nous amène à une addition finale d'un
peu plus de 100 chars Leclerc
opérationnel un échantillonnage selon
différents experts à comparer des
quelques 1500 chars dont disposait
l'armée française dans les années 80
alors ce qui nous donne déjà des indices
pour répondre à la question pourquoi
est-ce que on ne donne pas pour
important de char et bien sensiblement
pour les raisons que nous venons
d'évoquer vous l'avez dit l'éventualité
n'est pas à 100% écarté mais on pourrait
envisager trois scénarios le premier la
France envoie l'équivalent d'un escadron
c'est à dire 14 à 15 chars ce qui
relèverait plutôt du geste politique
pour des raisons techniques selon le
colonel Michel Goya écoutez
14 ou 50 ou 100 bah il faut derrière il
faut assurer la logistique
il faut assurer la maintenance surtout
c'est ça le plus compliqué un char
Leclerc ça nous coûte à peu près 20000
euros d'entretien par mois et voilà
l'entretien en France ou ils sont pas
engagés au combat donc vous imaginez ce
que la complexité de la chose s'ils sont
lorsqu'ils sont engagés au combat donc
il faut derrière il faut des pièces de
rechange il faut des chenilles il faut
des enfin tout un tas de choses sans
même parler du carburant
deuxième éventualité pour avoir un début
d'effet l'état envoie de quoi équiper un
bataillon blindé 40 à 50 chars en
intégrant l'idée de s'emputer d'un tiers
du stock dernière possibilité l'armée
cède l'intégralité de son stock et fait
l'impasse sur ces chars de batailles il
faudrait alors environ 15 ans au bas mot
pour s'en remettre c'est la moins
probable comment la France peut-être
apporter sa pierre et l'édifice bah de
plusieurs manières il y a d'abord la
possibilité d'envoyer du matériel autre
que des chars des véhicules de transport
d'infanterie par exemple blindé qui
accompagne les chars sur les champs de
bataille et qui leur sont essentiels
mais là aussi ça pêche un peu la France
n'en a et pas énormément à sa
disposition dans la véritable aide qui
est possible c'est celle technique les
Léopards 2 allemands allemands pardon
qui vont aborder de toute l'Europe en
des caractéristiques techniques et des
pièces qui sont compatibles avec le
matériel produit par l'industriel
français Nexter fabricant des chars
Leclerc la France pourrait donc apporter
un
de matière de maintenance merci Mathias
pour tous ces détails Gérard Longuet
avec la tonalité de cette fin
d'après-midi
bon il y a eu l'Allemagne dans la
journée il y a eu les Américains qui ont
confirmé l'envoi de charams puis la
Norvège à d'autres pays vont suivre
est-ce que la France peut rester en
retrait je parle bien de livraison même
on va parler des difficultés techniques
que ça représente mais le geste
symbolique de participer à ce ne peut
pas
rester en retrait sauf à offrir une une
voie diplomatique dont elle ne tient
détient absolument pas la clé
aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire je veux dire si
le président Macron avait en effet
établi des liens particuliers avec un
Poutine attentif est-ce que dit le
président français on pourrait imaginer
que la présidente Macron dise non on met
pas nos chars maintenant parce qu'on a
encore une carte à jouer mais on n'a pas
de carte à jouer donc il faut mettre les
chars alors ce que dit votre
intervenant est très pertinent c'est où
tout de suite
l'escadron symbole ou c'est assez
rapidement mais à ce moment là c'est le
bataillon c'est-à-dire 40 chars et quand
vous dites tout de suite ou assez
rapidement un mois la décision c'est
simplement il faut les faire rouler
parce que envoyer du matériel qui ne
servira à rien serait déshonnant alors
il faut bien comprendre aussi que la
France depuis la chute du mur de Berlin
considère que son terrain sont les Opex
et c'est l'Afrique et la Méditerranée
les Allemands eux sont restés sur une
idée simple
c'est à l'aise que ça se passe et c'est
dans les plaines de l'Ukraine justement
ou dans les plaines russes ou dans les
plaines polonaises que le jeu se fera
donc ils sont structurellement
adaptés à ce type de combat ce qui est
pas notre cas il faut bien et pas adapté
est adapté mais il est pas en quantité
en fait il y a eu 800 chars Leclerc
fabriqués dont à peu presque 400 pour
les Emirats Arabes Unis où il fonctionne
dans des conditions extraordinairement
difficiles d'une façon je qualifierais
de satisfaisante avec tout le côté un
petit peu cynique de ces adjectif et
puis 400 en France dont 200 sont sous
cocons c'est ce dont on parlait et le
souverain qu'on a commencé à rénover
rétrofiter les une soixantaine 80
d'entre eux qui sont donc des habillés
et pas utilisable immédiatement et ceux
qui restent il faut les remettre dans le
coup on envoyait en Roumanie je crois
l'équivalent à ma connaissance d'un
escadron deux escadron c'est à dire une
vingtaine de chats qui sont qui viennent
d'ailleurs de chez moi je crois des
premiers chasseurs ou de ou du camp de
maïs Patrick Martin Genier et est-ce que
au-delà du du
[Musique]
ou des fantons la France et là où
l'Europe nous interpelle et où la
décision de Scholtz nous interpelle
c'est que Scholl c'est notre voisin et
qui est plutôt pacifique l'Allemagne est
devenu heureusement un pays pacifique
heureusement nous dit faut y aller et à
ce moment-là comme il faut défendre la
France
vis-à-vis de son ennemi il faut la
défendre là où l'ennemi nous attaque et
l'ennemi nous attaquent sur les plaines
ukrainiennes monsieur chasse a mis très
longtemps avant de se décider il a
beaucoup positif par se décider donc
pour répondre à votre question qu'il est
décidé nous sommes obligés de nous
décider aussi simple donc je suis
d'accord pour dire d'abord que
effectivement une armée c'est d'abord
fait pour défendre les territoires le
territoire français national vous avez
raison de poser la question jusqu'où
cela doit aller ça pose la question
d'une défense européenne d'une meilleure
coordination on a vu que ça posait des
problèmes avec ça aussi il aurait fallu
défendre la France à sadova c'est-à-dire
en haut aussi pour répondre à votre
question je pense qu'effectivement il a
urgence de façon symb et politique
d'envoyer des chars Leclerc en Ukraine
Nicolas Tenzer alors là si on est sur le
terrain comment ils peuvent être
utilisés parce que là on est en train
d'empiler des technologies quand même
oui
les Abrahams et les Leclerc non c'est
pour ça que je dirais soyons
parfaitement sur le plan opérationnel
d'avoir ou non dès Leclerc ne changera
pas fondamentalement les choses il faut
être tout à fait clair là-dessus
c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui ce sont les
Léopards 2 s'ils ont un nombre suffisant
ce sont les Abraham ses mains aussi
américains s'ils sont non peut-être plus
importants que ce qu'annonçait le
président baiden aujourd'hui c'est ça
qui fera plus les autres armes que j'ai
évoqué qui fera la différence les
Leclerc surtout si c'est une petite
quantité ça va poser plus de problèmes
comme d'ailleurs les challenger 2
britanniques c'est exactement la même
chose d'ailleurs le modèle de défense
genre Longuet parlait effectivement des
opérations extérieures les Britanniques
ont fait aussi le même type de choix
militaire que même dans le passé alors
après ce qui était fondé ou pas c'est
une autre question donc c'est pas
l'essentiel en revanche si la France dit
maintenant effectivement parce qu'il y a
de plus en plus de demandes notamment
sur les avions et que la France pose
clairement sur le tapis cette question
là je pense que les ukrainiens et nos
alliés de manière générale apprécieront
effectivement l'engagement de la France
mais effectivement il faut y aller
jusqu'au bout donc c'est peut-être pas
crucial militairement mais
symboliquement
important bon Mathieu symboliquement je
posais une question peut-être absurde
mais
quelle est la différence symbolique
entre un canon César qui fait quand même
beaucoup de dégâts dans les lignes
russes de ce qu'on a pu voir et de ce
qu'on entend de la part des Ukrainiens
et un char lourd de combat aucune
différence si ce n'est que dans le cas
du char léopard c'est la République
fédérale d'Allemagne le premier pays de
l'Union européenne notre partenaire
principal qui nous dit et qui dit aux
autres on y va alors c'est assez quand
vous avez une équipe et quand il y a le
plus gros qui dit on y va celui qui est
à côté peut difficilement dire
maintenant je suis pris j'y vais pas non
mais il y a un grand supplémentaire
entre un canon
il y a un aspect technique mais il y a
surtout le la questionnement politique
on a des Russes qui élève le niveau
d'offensive et un voisin allemand qui
note partenaire principal dans la
construction européenne qui dit j'y vais
on fait quoi à nous
réponse dans les prochaines heures sans
doute la question des armements des
armes lourdes vous savez que jusqu'à
présent déjà non enfin de l'emporter il
ne faut pas envoyer des armements qui
puissent aller sur le territoire russe
on en parlait tout à l'heure mais si on
a commencé en disant armes
défensivement offensive
donc ça veut dire que il faut
effectivement donner tous les moyens à
l'Ukraine les canons les chats qui
puissent détruire les lignes russes très
très loin en Ukraine avec des risques
que ça puis aborder sur le territoire
russe on est d'accord mais si
aujourd'hui il faut donner tous les
moyens il faut savoir une chose c'est
que si on ne donne pas l'Ukraine tous
les moyens c'est une guerre qui va durer
encore des années
elle riche surtout de la perdre Nicolas
Tenzer voulais intervenir je pense que
sur ce sujet là je pense que le vrai
sujet et là nous devons nous occidentaux
nous regarder c'est à dire que si nous
avions été beaucoup plus rapide je
dirais pour donner l'ensemble de ces
armements que ce soit d'ailleurs des
chars que ce soit les canons Césars ou
ou les highmars ou toutes les autres
systèmes d'armement combien de vie de
dizaines de milliers de vie ukrainiennes
aurions-nous sauvé
je pense que c'est un vrai sujet de
conscience c'est un sujet je dirais pour
la conscience de nos dirigeants c'est
aussi un sujet je dirais par rapport à
des ambitions stratégiques et je pense
que petit à petit il va falloir aller
jusqu'au bout c'est à dire que là on est
passé si vous voulez au début de nous
défendons l'Ukraine nous aidons Ukraine
à se défendre maintenant nous sommes à
un stade pas complètement nous aidons
l'Ukraine à reconquérir tout son
territoire et nous nous rendons compte
aussi que ça passe troisième étape par
il faut défaire complètement la Russie
et je pense que conceptuellement ces
trois étapes seront et doivent être en
tout cas progressivement franchi
est très très vrai mais je pense qu'on
n'est pas
on est encore on tient la main c'est à
dire que détruire enfin bon je vais
construire la Russie c'est le terme je
disais
aujourd'hui d'abord qu'elle retourne je
dirais sur son territoire et qu'elle ne
représente plus parce que c'est un sujet
de un moyen et long terme une menace
pour l'Europe et pas seulement encore
une fois et je pense que là une affaire
diabolique et ça c'est la Russie je vous
rappelle c'est 17 millions de kilomètres
carrés on peut parfaitement enfin on
peut imaginons qu'on conduise l'armée
russe à ses frontières la Russie
continuera d'exister avec sa culture sa
population et son immense espace de de
protection et son champ stratégique la
seule solution vrai c'est une solution
politique c'est-à-dire que une façon ou
d'une autre la Russie trouve sa place
dans l'espace européen alors c'est pas
gagné et je pense qu'on a perdu deux
générations avec cette affaire je vais
proposer une voix un peu dissonante qui
pointe le risque d'escalade celle de
Pierre Lelouch ancien secrétaire d'État
de Nicolas Sarkozy dans une tribune au
Monde et il considère que l'aide massive
apporter à Kiev risque de ne pas
permettre de résoudre le conflit mes
deux l'aggraver je vais le citer voyant
ses défenses sur le point d'être emporté
grâce au moyen par l'OTAN le Kremlin
pourrait alors se considérer comme
fonder à frapper en territoire polonais
notamment les concentrations d'armes
occidentales ce qui déclencherait
l'article 5 de l'OTAN le risque très
réel d'un conflit ouvert
Nicolas Tenzer je commence avec vous
juste vous lui dites depuis le début de
ce de cette émission vous êtes forcément
en total opposition avec avec père
louche mais cette voix on peut
l'entendre quand même écoutez j'ai
beaucoup de mal à l'entendre parce que
tout simplement je vois très bien quels
sont les récits que les partisans du
Kremlin n'arrêtent pas de diffuser
aujourd'hui en France et de dans de
manière générale dans les pays
occidentaux il me faut plus dire sauf
quelques extrêmes nous soutenons le
Kremlin il y a des nazis en Ukraine
enfin tout ce narratif grossier et lourd
de la propagande en revanche le discours
moi je l'ai entendu en février en mars
avril il ne faut pas l'armée l'Ukraine
parce que ça va entraîner plus de
sacrifices des soldats Ukrainiens il
faut être beaucoup plus prudent parce
que attention il y a je veux dire c'est
un discours tellement catégorisé
qui me paraît effectivement
extraordinairement dangereux ça voudrait
dire concrètement je termine là-dessus
que nous aborderions non seulement nos
principes parce qu'on a quand même des
principes défendre un pays agressés dans
la charnalisation unique mais aussi que
nous menacerions notre avenir le vrai
sujet c'est aussi un sujet d'avenir la
frontière de la liberté est en Ukraine
aujourd'hui mais quand Emmanuel Macron
vous l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure je
voudrais bien entendre votre analyse
plus plus détaillée utilise ce mot de
escalatoires c'est quoi ça veut dire que
les menaces russes continuent de peser
sur voilà sur une
partie de voilà de l'équipe d'Emmanuel
Macron sur lui-même sur son inconscient
je ne sais pas c'est difficile
d'interpréter la pensée du président de
la République mais je crois que en
disant cela il veut envoyer de nouveau
un message à Vladimir Poutine en disant
qu'il reste toujours disponible pour
éventuellement discuter escalatoires ça
veut dire quoi en l'été il a peur que
Vladimir Poutine considère de l'envoi de
char constituerait une ligne rouge
inacceptable pour le Kremlin donc
aujourd'hui malheureusement il n'y a
plus de place pour la diplomatie il y a
la guerre il faut faire gagner l'Ukraine
mais il veut envoyer un message qui
risque encore d'être un peu inaudible du
côté de des Polonais et des Ukrainiens
même s'il entretiennent de meilleurs
relations donc il faut pas que ce soit
escalatatoire il faudrait pas que ce
soit le prétexte ou l'objet pour la
lumière Poutine par exemple d'évoquer de
nouveau une menace nucléaire c'est
peut-être cela qu'il veut faire passer
comme message avant ça l'hypothèse
Longuet que la Russie attaque la Pologne
par exemple d'ailleurs est-ce qu'elle en
a militairement les moyens aujourd'hui
non elle a les moyens de frapper je ne
suis même pas sûr que les moyens aérien
de frappé parce que la présence aérienne
russe en Ukraine est relativement faible
parce que le la défense c'est quand même
considérablement
renversé et surtout la Pologne c'est
l'OTAN et la défense entière aérienne le
temps est un peu et certainement au
bénéfice de la Pologne
comme une vis des pays baltes et demain
on bénéfice de la Finlande et de la
Suède non je crois que il y a un intérêt
que Lelouch ne voit pas le fait d'aider
son allié lui permet un moment ou un
autre de lui taper sur l'épaule en
disant on a fait tout ce qu'on a pu
faudra peut-être réfléchir à trouver une
solution si vous ne l'aidez pas vous
n'avez pas d'autorité pour le faire si
vous l'aidez vous avez une petite
autorité pour le dire et donc pour dire
à l'Ukraine dans quelques mois même si
même si tout le territoire n'a pas été
récupéré il est peut-être temps de
discuté quoi c'est ce que c'est ce que
vous nous dites au moins le retour aux
frontières d'avant le 22 février
c'est que le droit international encore
une fois est clair c'est à dire que si
on commence à accepter qu'un pays révise
la frontière de l'autre par la force
encore une fois y compris la Crimée bien
sûr et le le don de base de la période
enfin je dirais avant le 24 février
depuis 2014 ça devient effectivement
c'est un signal aussi qu'on donne à
d'autres choses mais s'il y a une
fenêtre d'opportunité à un moment pour
sortir de cette guerre par la voie
diplomatique ce serait une voie
dangereuse d'abord sur les principes
mais ce serait aussi une voix éphémère
c'est-à-dire que dès que la Russie
demain aura donc quand je dis demain
c'est dans 3 ans dans 4 ans je ne sais
pas aura reconstitué ses forces elle
reprendra ses attaques et Poutine pourra
dire mais vous voyez nous avons en face
de nous une sorte de prophétie ou
théorisatrice nous avons un Occident
faible
le coup de l'Occident faible parce que
là maintenant il va réfléchi et ça tu
pourrais faire pression à l'été ce sont
les États-Unis on a vu que la Maison
Blanche il y avait différents sons de
cloche et que le seul que va de volote
de manière générale ce qui pourrait
écouter ce serait bien le président
Biden qui est le chef de la Coalition
internationale oui donc même dans dans
sa stratégie et dans et dans cette
éventuelle porte ouverte d'avoir
accompagné de discuter avec Biden si on
discute pas directement avec
j'ai pas entendu ce que vous disiez je
dis d'être d'être d'accompagner Biden
dans cet effort permet de continuer à
discuter avec les États-Unis qui est
quand même qu'on le veuille ou non notre
partenaire même si il décide toujours
tout seul
qui a été très très important et qui ont
permis de lier d'avoir des liens très
importants non seulement avec le
président américain mais avec le Congrès
des États-Unis merci à tous les trois
d'avoir participé à ce premier débat qui
était passionnant au cœur de l'actualité
de cette fin d'après-midi
[Musique]
on ne le perd évidemment pas de vue
quand on mène un débat comme celui-là
mais merci de l'avoir rappelé merci
beaucoup